i think you're one of those people where
the audience needs to find you because
yes just because it's like look you're
gonna go into now as a marketing major
well i mean you're gonna go to any
comedy club in the country and you know
you're gonna you're gonna clear half of
them out if they don't know who you are
and because you've never been apologetic
which i've always really admired about
you and now people have found you
and so yeah and you know why uh thanks
to tommy my manager
really because he when he started
working about three years ago he goes
he goes the comedy world knows you
people that work at comedy sarah throw
you a peer
nobody knows who you are nick you know
and he
he he backs everything up he'd show me
numbers from youtube and and
that hurts and uh no but i i i sort of
knew
it doesn't hurt as much as one night in
new jersey in front of
he likes you 38 there's a pie chart as
to why you suck there's a pie chart
here's kevin hart no you might as well
jump
off him and commit suicide because
you're dying
yeah there's also 200 one-nighters in
north dakota so she could be worse